welcome everyone to today's topic on
devops tutorial for business
in this one we are going to talk about
that what is exactly devops and from the
business perspective what are the
different things
we can learn as and basics to get a
better clarity
now what exactly is there in for us so
first one is the advent of
devops what is devops industries
using devops why do we use devops
devops lifecycle and future of devops
here now the very first thing which we
need to talk about
is what is the advent of devops now so
devops is a kind of a process which
is like developed over the period of
time and it's not like
uh recently it's being launched here
it's co present quite there into the
industry but over the period of time yes
it have evolved
from some couple of automations and then
now we have got a
huge number of implementations around
the devops
so in the beginning there was like a
waterfall model
which is a pretty straightforward model
and it was one of the
first sdlc cycle or sdlc model which was
shared for the software development now
in this one
it was a kind of a mechanism where we
felt like
it's more on kind of a phase like a
phase
mechanism so there were like multiple
phases which
was present in this model this model was
pretty simple straightforward and easy
to use and implement also
there were not much of the complexity
which was there in this model it was
very straightforward
simple model for the development team
and the development team also felt
very comfortable around this model
because they don't have to
put up much more efforts on this one
it's a kind of a sequential
process in which each phase will be
executed one by one
once the previous phase is executed then
the next one will be proceeded
so the output of the previous one will
act as an kind of
input for the next phase
now these are some of the phases of the
waterfall model
so let's talk about that a little bit
now over here
these are the different phases like
requirements gathering
system design implementation testing
deployment and maintainers so these are
the different phases of the waterfall
model
now the very first thing which we have
over here is the
requirements analysis now when we are
working with the requirements analysis
over here
it means that in this phase you will be
focusing on taking up the requirements
from the end user
from the customers usually the business
owners or product owners
were taking up the requirements from the
business from the clients and they
used to record it as an functional
document they used to create the
functional document
and once the documentation is done like
all the requirements is done
then only they will be proceeding
further and i guess this is a
thumb rule also of the software
development that unless and until we are
clear about the
requirements we will not be able to
proceed further so
yes this requirement analysis stage is
very important because in this phase
you are taking up all the requirements
and whatever doubts you
have that is something you are trying to
get over here in this case
and it is uh something which will help
you
that it will perform all the activity
like whatever the task or
functionalities you want to implement
you will be able to collect all those
things in this particular phase here
then the second one is the system design
now system design again it's a kind of
a phase which will be only initialized
once the requirement gathering is done
so once the requirement analysis is done
then only you will be proceeding further
with the system design
in this system design you will be
preparing a design a kind of
architecture which you will be following
for performing the
development now this is a very important
part because
uh here you will be maybe you will be
having some issues some information is
missing
so that will be again checked over here
in this one
so once the design is done then only you
will be able to proceed further because
without the design
and if you directly go with the
implementation then you may face a lot
of difficulty
in understanding the proper requirement
so whatever doubts and clarity you want
to have
that will be having that will be
resolved during the design phase
now once the design phase is done then
only you will go for the implementation
now in case of
software development implementations
prescribes
about the software development so
software development
is what you're going to do in the
implementation now once the software
development is done so what you're going
to do is
that you are going proceeded with the
testing part
and testing is very important because
without testing
eventually you will not be able to go to
the production environment
so testing is something where we are
giving more focus on how
we want to test or validate the whole
application the whole product
uh you may be doing different kind of
testing like unit testing integration
testing
stress testing uh oat twisting
then uh the acceptance testing then
functional testing non-functional
testing so a lot of testing frameworks
you can actually use
and you can perform the testing over
there so testing is very important
because unless and until you don't do
the testing
you cannot proceed further with the
proper sign off and with all the
confirmations
then only we will go to the next phase
so again
the previous step should be successful
and should be completed
perfectly fine then only you can go
ahead with the next phase
now after the testing you will go to the
deployment phase
where you will be taking care about the
deployment now it can be a lower
environment deployment it can be like a
higher environment deployment
but it's a kind of a generic phase in
which you will be covering
that how you can do the deployment to
the production environment
and make your source code alive but
again if the testing is not done
properly
then you will not be able to reach out
to this face so in order to reach out to
this phase you need to make sure that
all the previous steps or the phases
should be successful
and once it's successful then ultimately
the last one is the maintainers or the
monitoring
where you will be just monitoring your
infrastructure on that part so these are
the different
phases of the waterfall model and again
if the previous phase is done
then only it will move the cursor to the
next one unless and until the previous
one is not done
it will not move ahead over here so
these are the different phases of the
waterfall model
right now what was the limitation of
this model if
we are already discussing about this
model and if we it's
so simple to understand so simple to use
and it's very simplified
so what are the different limitations
which was there with this waterfall
model because
again there is some reason that why this
particular model got
replaced so there could be our
limitations which is available
as part of this model here the very
first one is that it was difficult to
make changes
in the sequential model because this
sequential model is the same way that
how typically we do the development
so i cannot expect like testing to be
done prior to the development so that's
something which is
required as for the requirements the
testing phase
came extremely late in the process if
you see like
in all these different phases in this
one the testing is something which is
like
third last over here in this case which
means that
you are doing a huge number of steps a
huge number of work
and probably you know after a lot of
phases that's where you will be going to
the testing part
which can cause a serious problems
because
for instance you are working on a
functionality and from the beginning
you got the requirement wrong and you
are working on the particular
requirement you're trying to implement
it
you did the coding you did the
implementation now during the testing
only you will be able to know
whether the requirement was correct or
not because you will be putting some
inputs
you will be processing getting some
outputs so that's a very risky part so
and this particular moment the testing
phase is something which is coming
quite late in this whole waterfall model
and that's a remain reason why it's
causing the problem over here because
you are having so many limitations and
uh the testing is not done
immediately it's not done in the
previous phases
and uh whatever feedback you are going
to get that will be
quite late in the whole process
the next phase is that the client was
not included at any phase so
client involvement is not there so the
validations or the verifications
cannot be done by the client and if some
requirements are missing so we will not
be able to get it done from the clients
and the
uh involvement or the engagement with
the client is not there in any of that
particular phase
again there are high possibilities of
risk and certainties in the project
because
again the testing is done late you will
get less time for the testing
than the it's a phase five phase
mechanism so you cannot
do the changes to that pattern so all
these things cause
a high risk of over here for the project
since the integration took place between
the uh end
so it prevents the identification of any
challenges
so the deployments are being done quite
late
so you are working on the things and if
you feel like
your deployment is not working fine and
there is an issue with the deployment
so if you have the capability that you
can do some deployments prior to this
one
in this phase then i guess you will be
able to be there into a better position
because that will not cause any kind of
problem
now in this case you can see that the
particular integration is like the
deployment is happening quite
late almost the second last phase is
there for that part
so if there is any kind of problem in
the deployment if you are going for any
automated tool
or you're performing the the deployments
the releases
then that particular thing will be in
risk over there so
you need to uh focus on that also
because that's the biggest challenge
and maybe while doing the implementation
in the production environment you are
stuck with that
and you will start facing the problems
this model is again
not suited for long and complex projects
because again
for the complex projects you cannot
simply wait
for months to complete the previous
phases and then go for the deployments
and
do the releases so uh for small
and short projects this is more kind of
a comfortable model
but again for long and complex projects
this model is not that much comfortable
for that part
so now let's talk about the advent of
devops because we have already talked
about it what is the waterfall model
what are the limitations
and uh we will also talk about
much of the details about there so that
we can have a better clarity
now what is the advent of endeavors now
after the
waterfall model again there were some
problems serious problems which was
there in the waterfall model
then we got the agile model over here
now agile is relatively new as compared
to waterfall model
and the problems which we were facing in
the waterfall model
those are getting resolved in case of
agile so agile model is nothing but a
collaboration of iterative and
incremental models
in this one there is no phase by phase
mechanism rather than the phase
mechanism here we
have iterative and incremental models so
you are not going to complete the
activity in a single phase
but there will be like multiple
iterations which will be there
and these iterations can be incremental
so
the main focus of the agile is to
you know perform the teamwork customer
satisfaction and fast delivery
because this was the problems which we
were facing in the waterfall model that
the delivery is quite late because you
are doing all these steps and then you
are doing
everything in a sequence so that takes a
lot of time
and that's the reason why the
organization who are working on the
waterfall model
they used to take much for doing the
deliveries but
with the agile model we are pretty much
doing some releases every month
two weeks four week cycle is there and
the only reason for that is that this
model supports that
functionality now the industries were
facing a lot of problem
because the waterfall model was causing
a lot of problems in the terms of
delivery
and the industries cannot really wait
for uh
you know months for doing the delivery
now this was the problem because when
for example the other is in banking
sector and uh they want to release or
they want to work on some product now if
they take like six months of time
duration
for some integration for some delivery
to the client
then that particular client or the
customer will not be happy because
again for you know couple of months they
are not getting anything
so they feel that there is no work going
on there and
pretty much the business is so
competitive right now
that everyone wants to get the features
immediately
and that's a reason why some
organizations even
change the particular vendors just for
that purpose because the work is getting
delayed
and they want to go for a different
window which can provide the solution
in less duration of time so um the the
idea about these startups is all the
same concept because these startups are
not taking
years of time to do the uh particular
development or you know to do that
particular stuff
so they got some solution they put it in
the market and depending on the
feedback they keep on improving that and
that's the reason why most of these
startups nowadays are on the agile
because they want to focus on the
customers that what they require
now the customers requirement can change
over the period of time but again they
have to evolve they have to change their
product
accordingly to work and to get this
particular requirement so this is a very
important aspect from that part
next one the agile process is pretty
much divided into five phase
so the initialization planning
development release and retirement
now again this is not something which is
sequential
it's an uh iterative approach which
keeps on going so you can see here that
mention not in the phase mechanism this
is the biggest difference
between the waterfall and agile model
because in case of waterfall model you
can see that at that moment of time
it was all phase mechanism but here in
this case
you are talking about the iterations
here so these
are all mentioned as an iteration in
case of agile
and that's a reason why we are not doing
this stuff
or these steps in a particular time
duration so probably in a week
we are following multiple iterations of
doing the development performing the
testing
validations doing the deployment to any
lower environment so multiple times we
are following that
so iteration can be like n number of
iterations which you can follow over
there
and that's a reason why even if there is
any kind of requirement
let's say that you got a new requirement
changes in waterfall model
now it's a phase by phase mechanism
which means that once the planning is
done
once the design is done then you cannot
change it you cannot proceed with that
but due to the iterative nature there is
a possibility
that the same thing you can do it again
you can take up the requirements
and that's the reason why in the agile
process adding up the
new requirements is pretty easy as
compared to the waterfall model
right so let's talk about the uh
particular limitations of the agile
model here
and before that we can talk about like
what are the different things which we
are performing
in the agile mechanism like what are the
different phases which is available
there in this
particular agile model but again this is
not a sequential manner it's not a phase
by phase mechanism
it's something in which we are talking
about a kind of iteration and the
diagram also is mentioned in the same
way
now initialization means that in which
we will be taking up the gathering like
uh taking up the requirement so we
probably use the uh jira dashboards
jira tool for doing the project
management and tracking the things
tracking the springs and the
requirements
then we have the planning so we perform
the planning over there that will
what different developers are going to
work on these items
user stories so these user stories
contain all the requirements which is
being assigned to the developers and
they
work on that then development goes on
with the specific programming language
they work on some id tools they work on
the build tools so they
start to combine or start to get along
with the
version control system and on daily
basis they start doing the development
process
and then the release again in which we
are doing the deployment so
jenkins ubunku deploy excel deploy there
are so many tools which is available
using which you can perform the
deployments or the releases
and then the retirement is there which
is being followed after the
release and then we can have the
monitoring and all that stuff
so this is again a kind of phase in the
agile model which ensures you that
you are pretty much in a good shape as
for the process perspective
now what are the different limitations
of the agile model again anything
cannot be an ideal a perfect there so
there might be some
limitations which will be there in the
agile model so
let's talk about that the first one is
that the output
with this model comes so fast to the
market
that it's very difficult to get a
combined
output because again it's an iterative
approach so it's not a phase by phase
mechanism
so in phase by phase mechanism whatever
end result you're going to get
that's something which gets at the end
of the phase but in this one since
it's an iterative approach so you may be
getting like
multiple fragments like multiple units
you may be getting like
individual ones and it's not easy for
you to
uh combine the output like what are the
output you're getting so it's not an
easy task for you to combine that so the
final output is not pretty much clear to
you and it could be a possibility that
uh
since it's doing the delivery so much
faster the product is getting so much
faster here
so you may not get the full output as in
single unit
in that particular moment of time so
that's a limitation so
it gets fragmented here and there and uh
you may have to like put your efforts in
order to combine those and
maybe one portion is ready but the
second portion is not ready and then
again
you have to wait for the second portion
to be ready so that you can
deliver both the things into a final
delivery to the
product to the market there so this is
the limitation the very first limitation
which is there from the agile
perspective the estimation of cost time
and resources
is difficult at the beginning of the
project because again we are talking
about that this is a kind of iterative
approach
in case of waterfall model what happens
that the requirements are feased
and since once the requirement is a
process is done then only we go for the
implementation process
process so during the implementation so
we are pretty much clear that what we
need to implement
what are the different things we want to
uh perform and how much time it's going
to take
but here in case of agile the estimation
can be different because
again in some of the iteration you may
get an additional work
and uh the things can change over the
period of time
so it's not a phase-by-way mechanism
that's the reason why there is an
uh kind of a chances for getting some
changes in the requirement so that's
always possible in the agile model then
the process of documentation
becomes limited so the documentation is
something which is not being taken care
as that much focus
during the agile model but again if you
improve this one if you
focus more on the documentations in
agile we have the like different
technical writers we can have technical
writers who can focus on the
documentations
which can do the work for the for the
development team and
in that case we can manage this stuff
that whatever the documentation we are
lagging behind
we can prepare that we can cover up that
with the help of the technical writers
who can give more focus on this uh
and that can be done on the behalf of
the development team
so that will reduce that gap and
ultimately this can be easily handled
to resolve the problem but again it's
one of the limitation which is there
from the process perspective
now these limitations it depends on your
organization that
if you got some process and a kind of a
modifications
then you can definitely get rid of all
these ones
then the spirit of the collaboration now
teamwork is
very important for any any model to be
success
but in this case it's pretty much
required and uh
in order to because earlier the people
were working on the waterfall model
now if you go back and say that we want
to work in a different model
and there we require a little bit more
collaboration then
it also depends on the human there that
how exactly they want to react
now collaboration is not something which
you can automate with certain tool or
you can change overnight
it will take some time to have the
collaboration and in some cases this
collaboration even fail also
it's all possibility that's a reason why
it's considered as a limitation
that the collaboration which we are
looking forward in the agile
is something which is the biggest
challenge and implementation is one
challenge and maintaining that
collaboration
is another challenge there so these are
some of the limitations which we
face while working on the agile model
with this model
only the professional people can
actually take the decisions the whole
process the whole development process
is something which is given to the
professional
experienced people only and if someone
is not that much experience
then the decision making mechanism or
process will not be involved for that
so only the experienced professionals
are given the full control
or the decision making capability for
the development process here right and
uh with this process again
there is no clarity that what the final
product is going to look like
because all the things are going to
happen in a fragmented manner
so uh you may miss the clarity that what
will be the final output
and once all the iterations are done
once all the
work is done then only you will be able
to know that this is the work which you
are looking forward but before that
there is always a scope of
doubt on that particular part so these
were some of the limitations
in the agile and that's where now we
finally come up with the devops because
whatever the limitations were there in
the agile model
some of them gets implemented or gets
resolved with the help of devops
so let's talk about the devops here now
what exactly is in devops process all
about
so devops is nothing but a combination
or a collaboration of
dev and operation teams so these two
teams
are actively working in performing any
kind of release and deployments
but what happens usually is that they
don't interact much with
each other and in case of any issues or
any kind of problem
they don't have the uh capability they
don't have the
skill set to help each other on that
part so operation teams
does not have the capability of the
skill to help the development
to resolve the problems and the same
thing goes for the development also
so this is a kind of a gap which was
there in the industry
which was causing a lot of delays so
during the issues it was very difficult
for them to resolve the issues and
that's the reason why
the devops comes into the picture
because devops is
a kind of a collaboration between the
dev and ops team so
they have to collaborate with each other
and this collaboration should be done
so that they can come together and come
to a single
particular place and they uh try to
explore that what are the problems which
is there with the systems
in case they are stuck with any problem
they can help to resolve that
if there is any kind of installation
process or
process mechanisms so that can also be
resolved here
now it's a set of practices that work
to automate and integrate all the
processes between the
software and the development and the i t
teams whether it's a build automation
deployment automations
automated testing then release
deployment so all these work
which being done by the teams manually
is something getting purely automated
over there
and when these getting automated it's
also performing the collaboration
because the development network requires
like build
preparing the builds uploading to
artifactory creating the artifacts
and the operation teams has to work on
that and get it from the artifactry
download it
install it and perform the deployments
now if we get this processes automated
that means that we got the collaboration
between the two teams
and it's all happening automatically so
no one has to sit on the system and they
have to do these things manually because
these are pretty much being
happening automatically over there so
this is again a very important process
because
devops ensures that whatever the
particular manual stuff or
manual work you were doing earlier in
the waterfall model or before that
that completely gets automated and when
we are talking about this automations
it means that we are giving more focus
on the mo
common processes like cicd pipelines
deployment automations
release management and all these
concepts are
autumn continuous testing over there so
these are some of the processes
which we are focusing on the devops
right and again it reduces the gap also
because when we are talking about the
collaborations
which means that we are reducing the gap
which was there in the development and
the operation teams
so they don't have to uh get
against each other that this is not my
work this is not my work
so all these things are not being done
in that way so it's all about the
process that how exactly we can do the
organism
on the particular devops implementation
so
it uh improves the work culture whatever
the gaps are there whatever the
culture gaps or the collaboration gaps
are there so that can be
filled with the help of devops because
it focuses
more on the collaboration between the
development and the operation teams here
right and ultimately it improves the
efficiency because it's
doing the collaboration it's bringing
the teams together and
that helps to uh move ahead with the
business and improve the efficiency here
and
this is a very important aspect because
organizations are looking forward for
the faster releases
and not only the faster releases but the
efficient releases also
now devops supports or provides some
solutions like ci cd pipelines
which can make your delivery a much
faster
and at the same time you can have so
many quality gates
implemented like automated testing
performing uh
the work performing the executions
performing the installations
going for the environment setup so all
these things can be automatically
implemented and that's the uh solution
which we are getting with the devops so
devops is
trying to focus on how fast it can make
the whole release process
to that particular point right now let's
talk about the industries who are using
the devops here
now there are several companies or
organizations who are using devops over
the period of time
now some of them is the netflix and
amazon now netflix
used to deliver the dvds there through
the courier through the
mail service now there was some time
duration where we they caught the
downtime to that mail service right so
netflix
uh is something which got evolved from
the
shipping dvds to streaming videos over
the web
now the culture made it possible for
amazon also to predict
how much equipment it should buy to meet
the traffic demands
so both the organizations actually
implemented devops
to get some improvements in their
process now netflix was something which
was shipping the dvds but
suddenly they got in downtime in the uh
particular
mailing service because again it depends
it depends on the human nature right
so there were a lot of dependencies on
the mail service for that
and that's where they thought that let's
go ahead with that they
implemented devops they implemented the
cloud and that's where they move their
infrastructure to the
aws cloud and then they you know got
this whole online streaming product into
the
market and i guess this is one of the
most
popular product right now because they
are more focused on
doing the online streaming and at the
same time amazon is doing
a lot of automations around the devops
because they are providing us the devops
tools
they are providing us the ready-made
devos tool solutions
and they are also implementing such a
huge infrastructure
and that cannot be possible with the
devops so they have different tools
implemented there
and they are also doing releasing or
putting up the
updates to so many services through
their
automated mechanism so both the
organizations
are using the devops for improving the
efficiency of their product
right next one is the nasa and the
walmart here now the uh
devops made it possible for the nasa to
analyze the tata from the
mars rover curiosity now again the thing
is that
the nasa is an organization which is
dealing with
with a huge of chunks of data from the
different sensors
uh from the different satellites now
they cannot do all this stuff manually
and that's a reason why and sometimes
for them
it's not possible for them to get a huge
infrastructure
let's say they want to process an image
at that moment of time you can
understand like
you know when the image of sun comes and
the picture
so they were like it was it wasn't huge
in size so they had to put up a huge
computing power
to process to render that image now nasa
cannot create
the infrastructure on daily basis but on
the other hand they can actually use the
aws cloud
to create a huge infrastructure and then
they can render
this image with that particular cloud
platform so this
is the reason why nasa is required these
kind of cloud computing and devops
processes
so that it can automate the things it
can process a huge chunks of information
and this information is very important
so that's the reason why nasa proffers
goes within devops and try to implement
all this stuff
and at the same time walmart is also
kind of big retailer
and you know in order to reach out to
the different people at the same time
and uh you know processing the payments
getting their orders done
it's not possible without devops so
devops helped walmart
to scale up in case of the sales and
during the
year end sales the walmart is getting
automatically scaled up depending on the
traffic
so depending on the traffic the
scalability is something which they are
able to get with the help of devops so
the devops processes helped
walmart to increase their infrastructure
without doing this thing
manually so that's the main focus on
that right the next organizations is the
adobe
and the facebook here now these are also
quite popular organizations and adobe is
some is an organization which was giving
more focus
on the photoshop
then uh the illustrator is there a lot
of full
tools are available there from the adobe
now these are all desktop solutions
which was there
but now with the devops they have moved
on to the cloud based solutions
so they are focusing on the cloud
solutions where you can actually use
these uh particular softwares and uh
you don't have to like uh install these
ones into your local systems now
you can use it pretty much from the
cloud from the website so from the web
portal
and that can give you a whole together
different experience
now this is something which is only
possible because they got that
particular
infrastructure with the help of devops
and at the same time
facebook is a kind of a social media
which everyone is using
and devops helps the the automated csd
pipelines and devops processes helps
them
to deliver the changes updates because
you can see that uh
frequently the facebook is uh is
changing or releasing out the changes
and they are not asking for the downtime
they are not saying that in this
duration of time that
the environment will be down or this
facebook will be down
so they are doing that while the
environment is up and running with the
help of devops processes
and they are pretty much doing it with
their automated pipeline so they are
delivering lot of changes during the
business hours
to the customers to the end users here
so these are some of the industries
who are like the top notch over there in
their category
and they are using devops for that
implementation so you can imagine
that how important this process is for
the organizations right now
so next one is that why exactly we do
use
devops here there are some of the couple
of
reasons for this devops implementations
let's talk about that
the very first one is the adaptability
now devops is something which is quite
uh
adaptive to the market trends to the
changing
uh market trends here and that is the
reason why
because uh getting the results during
this market trends is a very tricky part
so devops is something which can help us
in order to get an
efficient and best result out of this
changing
market trends because um if we are
talking about the trends in the market
so it can be there from the
requirement perspective or it can be
there from the infrastructure
perspective
so the automations will help you to get
more and more functionalities into the
market
and you must have seen that if a new
platform
if a new payment gateway is coming up
immediately all the e-commerce websites
start releasing out the integration with
that
and that's the main focus because
whatever the trends are coming up the
organization since that
and they start working on that and their
devops processes
will help them to release out into their
products so they don't have to wait for
six months
or that much duration of time to get
that product to get that integration
the second one is the faster delivery
now this is the main reason why
organizations prefer the devops and the
agile here because
they are able to get like fast release
cycles
now these early cycles will help them to
uh to do the delivery in the production
environment much faster
and when we are talking about a proper
implementation of devops
eventually with this fast delivery you
will get quality also
because quality is also matters with the
quantity because
the you are getting a lot of
requirements
a lot of deployments are happening a lot
of releases are happening
and at the same time if the quality is
not met properly then it's going to be a
problem over there
so quality is and very important over
there
which is being taken care in this case
so faster delivery with the proper
quality is an important concept
while implementing devops now
reliability is also there because
if your infrastructure is not reliable
you have created some couple of servers
and infrastructure
and if they are not reliable they are
not available to you
and they goes down frequently then
that's something we need to focus
so reliability again within auto scaling
features there are some concepts high
ability and all
in the devops which gives you the
capability that even if there is any
kind of
issue with the for the infrastructure
the infrastructure is faulty
then it can spin up a new infrastructure
or it can replace the infrastructure
there
there are some solutions where you can
actually go for the auto scaling
to have new infrastructure created and
to add up
new uh computing power to your overall
uh resources so reliability is something
which we have got
with the devops processes when it
combined with the cloud computing it can
perform wonders to your projects
then they improve collaboration so
devops
mainly focus on the collaboration and it
actually
helps us to see that how we can improve
or how we can go with this collaboration
so
the teams gets collaborated with each
other so their core
values they get an more sense of the
ownership the end-to-end responsibility
so all these things are possible with
the help of the collaboration
which devops is primary focusing so
devops is focusing on this collaboration
and that can help them to understand
that how the collaboration
can be performed while doing the devops
implementation
next we have the security so again there
are some processes like dipsy cops which
is available which
is an extension of the box where we can
focus on how
the security can be implemented and try
to make sure that
uh it can be done or it can be
implemented over there so this is again
very important because
there is like a kind of a mechanism
where we focus that how
we want to make sure that our
applications or our infrastructure are
secure
and there should not be any scope for
the human errors
so security is also important and that's
something for which we are using the
devops
right now let's talk about the devops
life cycle here
now this is pretty much a kind of
a process like which is available a kind
of complete life cycle which is there
so it starts from the development
integration
testing monitoring feedback deployment
and operation so this is what we got in
the complete life cycle here
now a complete project the projects are
actually
going on there on the implementation
that how they can go for this
collaboration because
this collaboration is very important
from that perspective
and uh another important concept of this
one is that it
really helps them to go all these
different free
like different processes which is being
there so
complete hdlc cycle is something which
is being managed
easily within this devops life cycle so
let's focus on that
let's discuss one by one over here in
the complete life cycle of this area
now the very first one is the
development over here now development
is something which is being taken care
by the developers and they focus on this
one but again
they use a lot of modern tools modern
devops tools for this particular
approach
there are some uh processes like
continuous development
which takes care of this functionality
now continuous development helps the
developers to do the
development work and in this one we are
talking about like
how the world development work can be
planned and we can go with the
requirements because ultimately the
continuous development is nothing but
converting the requirements into the
actual source code so that's something
which we are looking forward from that
perspective
it's a very important process because
ultimately
in this whole mechanism we are looking
forward to how the source code
can be converted in the source into the
actual source code
and this source code can then be used or
can be used for the further steps like
testing deployment and all this stuff
so the during the coordinates
development the developers uses a number
of tools
jira eclipse visual studio
uh notepad plus plus so these all
different tools can be used
by the developers during the continuous
development process there
now the uh devops tools which is like
which is being
mostly utilized into this continuous
development process
is git because um the uh eclipse
netbeans the visual suit kodi studio
so these are all tools which uh is
checking out the source code
from the git version control system you
can pretty much have
like other version control system also
but devos is something which is being
focusing on some of the
uh modern tools because that's the idea
about the devops
if you are going with an implementation
of devops you have to go with latest
tool
and the efficient tool now git is one of
the efficient tool as compared to
any of the ocean control systems here
right now git is something which will be
taking care like
uh for performing the uh management of
the source code it's a version control
system
so it enables the developers to
collaborate with each other
if there are multiple developers working
on the same project so they can only
collaborate with each other
using the version control system using
git repositories
so whatever the modifications they are
doing to the source code they can do the
check-ins they can perform the merges
they can work on the branching so a lot
of concepts they can actually work
when they want to work on the version
control system so git is one of the
primary tool
which is being used for that purpose
where they are focusing on how the
version control system can be used to
have a collaboration between the teams
and this totally depends on which
version control system you want to use
but kit is one of the
most efficient tool which is available
there in this category
next one is the it's the integration and
in this one we basically implement the
quantities integration
now continuous integration is in process
where we are focusing
on how exactly uh the the
integration of the source code from the
local system
to the centralized version control
system happens over there
now uh developers keep on working on the
development
but keeping the source code to their
local system will not help them
so they have to eventually move this
source code to the
version control system to the gate
version control system and that's where
they will be able to have the
integration so this process helps on to
how
the source code can be integrated into a
centralized uh
repository like git version control
system central repository
and then how we can get the uh
particular we can perform the build
deployments and all that stuff we can
perform over there so all the
build process and everything we can
perform we can have we can
perform the mechanism over here in this
case so that's a continuous integration
process
which we are looking forward over here
right now so um there are a lot of other
tools which is also available there in
the continuous tools
and one of the most modern and the
latest tool is the jenkins
now jenkins can help you to automate
each and every bit
piece of the continuous integration
process whether
it's running the build tool whether it's
running the
automated test cases if we summarize or
if we say
uh into a single line what is exactly
continuous integration
process then we can refer to it as and
like
see the build automation and the
deployment and the uh test cases
automation here so these two things is
what
we relate with the continuous
integration process
right now so jenkins is an complete open
source tool
which is known as one of the prime
continuous integration tool there
now it helps you to build the source
code perform the testing
and it's very easy for the developers to
integrate all these changes
so whatever the uh mechanism whatever
the system we are trying to help
so jenkins is something which can
definitely help you to see that how
the automations can be done and how it
can help you to make the things better
so the developers don't have to do the
build
manually they don't have to run the test
cases manually eventually with the help
of complete ca process
they are making sure that how the builds
and the test cases can be automated in a
proper manner so that's what we are
looking forward
from the jenkins as in primary
continuous integration tool
now the next one is the testing now this
testing life cycle is something where we
are focusing on the continuous testing
now testing is one very important part
and
in the previous uh models testing was
being done pretty much manually
and it was like a huge impact on the
overall
life cycle of the project because there
is a huge efforts which is involved
into the manual testing and there is
always a scope of human error
now if we are looking forward for an
efficient uh
mechanism and we feel that the testing
can be done in efficient manner
that's where we need to go for the
continuous testing because this process
says that how exactly we can perform the
various kind of automations
around the testing whether it can be a
regression test cases whether it's kind
of a
stress testing because these are some of
the testing which can
eventually take a huge amount of time
for the testers
now if we somehow automate this ideal
approach is that
we should be going for everything
automated from the testing perspective
but again if you are uh going or if you
are
working on the migration then in that
case some of the testing like stress
testing regulation test cases
these are all things which you can
automate and then we can easily
integrate them within the pipelines
so that we can validate our source code
and it also helps you to increase
to check what kind of quality of source
code you are working over here
so that benefit also we are going to get
with the help of continuous testing
because
whatever the end result you get it's
always a high quality source code which
we
are getting with the help of this
process so that's the reason why
this process is quite important from
that perspective
now selenium is one of the most common
tool devops tool which is available
there in this case
now selenium can test any web
application so if you want to hit on a
web application
you want to replicate okay i want to log
in i want to do some basic stuff
now usually human or manual person will
be doing that stuff
but with this tool you can actually
automate that how some request
can be carried out through a website
through a web browser
and these are all things can happen and
it can take up the screenshots
it can uh you know take up the results
and inputs and all these things will be
given back to the results to the end
user so end user will be able to know
that what exactly it's trying to perform
over here and this whole
uh option it will help you to understand
that these are the different
requirements
or these are the different inputs you
have put up on this one and
that's how you got a complete clarity
that these are the
outputs you're getting and the end
result so selenium is one of the best
tool
for automating that uh if you want to
perform the activity if you want to test
the
web applications then it's one of the
option for that
the next one is the monitoring now from
monitoring we talk about the continuous
monitoring over here
so it's a kind of a phase lifecycle
phase where we
fix on that how what is the uses of our
application how our application looks
like because
there is a real-time traffic which is
through flowing through your application
now earlier people were only focusing
organizations only focusing on the
infrastructure monitoring
but now there isn't more focus on the uh
particular uh application monitoring
also because it's not only about the
uh functionality it's not only about it
how we want to go ahead and we want to
make a mechanism so we are not focusing
at all onto the uh only infrastructure
monitoring but we are also focusing that
how exactly our application will look
like whether the application will look
like fine
the application monitoring should be
there if application is working fine or
there is some
stress on the application you're getting
the failures so all these concepts you
are able to get with the
monitoring tools with this one now there
are a lot of tools which is there in the
monitoring tools
aspect but negatives is one of the tool
which is most commonly used
and it's one of the famous devops tools
available from the industry
now nexus is available as an open source
and enterprise both solutions
there are like one negotia monitoring
tool
the uh nego's log analyzer then network
tool is all separate there
so there are so many products which is
there from the negos
and a lot of organizations actually
trust negos
because they are having the
understanding that this tool is being
there in the industry
and a lot of promising organizations are
actually using it
and it helps you to detect that what is
the impact like
you know whether you're getting any kind
of down times your application is not
behaving as
promised all that clarity you're going
to get with the help of niger so negus
is something
which is pretty good tool from that
monitoring perspective
then we have the feedback now in this
one we talk about the continuous
feedback
now this hail stage helps us to get the
frequent
feedback from the end users more and
more releases you are doing
more and more feedback you are getting
so that's a quick feedback
you don't have to wait for months to get
the feedback that whatever the product
you are
preparing now if you do uh if you have a
release cycle of three months
it means that your product uh feedback
you will be able to get after three
months
but if you are doing like pretty much
frequent releases so every month you
will be able to get the result that this
is the
end uh release or this is the feedback
you're going to get for your product
so these are things are very important
from our perspective that how we want to
perform
or we want to proceed with this
mechanism then we always have the
deployment now deployment is something
which is
focusing on that how the continuous
deployment can be achieved
now we usually prefer uh refer to the pi
to the terminology called ci cd
pipelines
so in that case continuous integration
refers to the build process to the test
cases automation
whereas on the other hand the deployment
process is uh ensuring that how
you can deliver your product to a
specific environment get it deployed
with a perfect accuracy so continuous
deployment again
it's being done so that you can release
your source code
you don't have to build it and then go
there and do the deployments manually
it's all part of the automated process
which we are looking forward over here
so continuous deployment is in process
using which you can perform that
activity
there are so many tools which is
available there and one of the most
common
and the famous tool on this category is
the docker so docker
helps the developers to package their
product to package their
application and then using the docker
and kubernetes tool you can actually go
one step ahead
and deploy these containers on the
production environment so whatever
application you
perform you put up in this containers
that can run on the docker containers on
the docker host
and then you will be able to get the
similar web application deployed over
here
again the microservices cantonization
there are a lot of other processes
which is also getting implemented with
the help of docker here
so docker is pretty much one of the
famous continuous deployment tool which
is available
in the industry now the next one is the
operations now in this one we have the
continuous
operations over here which aims on that
how we can uh
manage our operations how we are working
on those components
how we can do the various automations uh
infrastructure management
configuration management tools
deployments managing the operations so
all these things comes under the
continuous operations category now let's
talk about the future because we have
seen that
what exactly the devops is having the
capability right now
and what is uh it's doing the wonders in
the different different industry
but what about the future so feature of
devops is quite bright
now it could be like uh not the same
technology the same tools are being
implemented
but it's something which is uh being
evolved over a period of time
so there are trends that devops is going
to move ahead
with such technologies like machine
learning
artificial intelligence security field
and infrastructure as code
now these may be present right now but
there is more integrations
which we are looking forward from the
future perspective
also the organizations are actually
having a huge demand
maybe there are very few organizations
who are not working on agile right now
because
pretty much everyone is going on agile
and this is not the choice of the
organization now
even in fact the clients are also now
coming up with the approach that they
require
agile process in the product which they
are using and if you
uh don't move on to that that's make
your customers unhappy so
in order to make your customers and
business good you
have to go with the agile process so
devops
role is going to be pretty common
nowadays and there's a huge demand
definitely there are very few devops
engineers which is there because
there is a demand on different different
tools
one devops role completely differs from
other because there is a dependency on
tools which you learn
but again there is a huge demand on what
are the different devops
professionals which is there in the
industry so there has been
70 person increase in the organizations
who adopting the devops
in 2018 and 10 percent in 2019
so again this is the change this is the
increase and it's being done or it's
bill
it will increase by year by year because
every year
some organizations are moving on so some
organizations are still planning
because ultimately everyone's goal is
that they want to go for this agile and
when we talk about agile
definitely devops will come in the
relationship and in a
complete package with that now let's
talk about the
monetary aspect here so around in 2017
so 3.36 billion is the overall market
which is being generated
over there in 2017 so around 3.36
billions
got generated in 2017 and the same thing
is expected to generate around 9.40
billions by 2023. now
again you know there is isn't kind of an
average like a national average salary
for a devops engineer
which is around like six to six point
seven lakh per annum
now this is something which is coming up
from the uh particular glass store and
salary there are different portals
where you can explore that what are the
different trends which is available
there
so from there you will be able to
understand the different devops trends
in around different globe around the
world
and at the same time you will be able to
get like different roles
which can give you the understanding
that what different uh
salary packages you're going to expect
but relatively as compared to any other
profile the packages in case of devops
is pretty
unique and pretty high because again
for couple of like let's say there 400
developers there will be like one or two
devops engineer which will be
available there so you can see the ratio
and depending on that you will get the
uh particular benefits right so that's
it for this
module i hope you liked it thanks
everyone
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here